好啊，说到这里啊。
嗯，最后我给大家提一些。
做编剧的一些准备工作和一些刻意的训练的方法。
首先一个准备工作呢，我希望。
每个人准备一个键盘。
有电脑的就不用了，电脑上有键盘。
拿着手机拿着pad吧。
以后不要这样上课。
我不希望。
大家要写东西的时候，你给我在那戳九宫格。
编剧是个艰苦的工作。
需要大量的写作辨习。
你也会爱上写作的机械键盘，那种敲击感，那种仪式感。
会让你有快感的，好吗？准备一个键盘。
然后呢，第二呢准备一个小本。
嗯，一个口袋本。
像我这样的口袋本儿。
带笔的每天随身带着，每天随身带着。
记什么呢？记素材记两种素材。第一，大量的看片。
去看优秀的作品，看不同风格，不同类型的作品。
因为看片儿是能让你最快速的去体会。
不同的。
人生不同的遭遇的一种方式。
比如说你去看一个杀手的片子。
这种你这辈子能体验到杀手杀人前的那种感觉吗？
你就要去去去去看那些片子，去体会他们的处理方式。
这是最快的方式。
第二呢，还记哪种素材呢？记你生活中的素材，因为这些素材是最真实的。
你能最真切的感知他。
比如说你今天。
同学叫你出去吃饭，说毕业十年了，聚会一下吧，你就拿上你的小本。为什么？你今天会记到很多。
装逼炫富的。
呃那个那个情节和台词，对吧？
有人去了，就把这个车钥匙往桌上一扔，还有人去了，就说哎今天都不要AA呀，谁也别抢，我买单，对吧？这种比较实惠的呃炫富也有，还有的呢就喜欢提名字。哎呀，我们公司呢跟阿里巴巴合作比较多，上次跟马云开会啊，哎呦呦呦马老板这建林呢他是怎么回事？
就这个提名者。
形形色色都有你这都是很好的素材，很真实，你需要去记，还有什么男的见到呃男女以前是旧情人，他们见面是怎么怎么回事，对吧？你这些都可以记嘛。
包括你说这次疫情。
嗯，结束以后你回去上班。
一看这公司。
这么长时间没开张，也快黄了。
然后老板呢就过来拍拍你家嘛，说小刘啊。
到我办公室来一趟。
你一拍大腿就知道了这。
老板这是要开除我呀，对吧？小本呢拿着小本进去，为什么你这辈子能被开除几回呀？这么这么珍贵的一线材料，你不记吗？
对吧老板家，哎呀，小刘啊。
你来公司也已经三年了，然后好先写先说时间轴，然后我其实有时候不把你当员工，我把你当兄弟啊，好，喷亲戚又记下来了，对吧？这些都很珍贵，记一下。
记一下。
这个习惯是所有创作者的习惯，不光是编剧，所有的创作者都有这个习惯，你去看就好了，这不是我一个人的习惯。
我这个习惯已经坚持十年十多年了，我基本上从刚入行就就开始有这个习惯了。我我知道这个窍门。
我们跟大家讲一个很夸张的事情。
我我我寄素材寄到什么程度？
很多年前啊。
我父亲去世了。
说到这里啊，你们心里基本上就有数了。
知道我我下面要说什么了？确实。
那天嗯他是凌晨去世的，然后我因为不在老家。
我买了早上最早一班飞机飞回去，然后落地开始。
一天之内处理所有的事情。
包括火葬场啊。
殡仪馆呀下葬呀，然后很多亲戚啊。
这个同村的人都过来招呼。
一天其实都处于一个非常懵逼。
忙碌。
的状态。
跟我以前对一个人失去亲人后的反应。
的想象。
是不一样的。
所以我忍不住把它记下来啊，同学们。
然后。
到了当天晚上，送走所有人之后。
才开始第一次哭。
眼泪。
我感觉那不叫哭。
那叫放水。
就是眼泪真的是第人生第一次体验，眼泪哗哗的流。
像往外喷一样的流。
然后是因为它流的流的速度太快。
那个水的。
那个那个那个。
力量从你的嗓子眼里。
抽出了。
声音。
是机械的裤刑被瞪出来的那种。
原始的声音不我感觉那不是哭，就是那种感觉。
太真实了。
也太珍贵了，所以我就记下来。
像这种素材，我不希望你们经历，你们可以抄我的，我借给你们抄一抄，好吧。
然后这是呃这是一种嗯素材也需要记。就是呃你有着这个小本以之后，既要记看片的那些多样的素材，又要记自己生活中各种真实的素材。你会养成这个习惯的。而且我告诉你，你会受益无穷，受益无穷。
你看到一个好的场景，记下来，对吧？今天去吃饭，前面一对情侣排队，然后一个美女从他俩身边走过就观察。
这一对情侣产生的化学反应，这个男的想看，但不看，先看看女朋友有没有看自己，对吧？这细节你去记，或者是今天碰到一个人物特别有特点，也可以去记，都去记，好吧。
你会养成这个习惯。
然后。
要做编剧，还有一个刻意的训练，你生活中你可以做的就是叫共情。
共情啊。
共情是什么意思呢？就是同理心。
同理性，这个是对于写作非常重要，对于创作非常重要。因为你将来创造每一个角色的时候，你都要走到他的内心去想他为什么要这么做，他是怎么想的。
共体。
这个怎么练呢？在生活中，比如说就还说你回到公司，你老板要开除你。
你。
当然有点生气，有点失望，有点难过。但是你如果站在他的心里呢？
你站在他的角度。
就是说你带入一下，你共情一下，你站在他的角度，你想你是这个公司的老板。
你现在遇到这种状况，你怎么处理？
然后手下这5个兵，5个员工。
你开除谁？
搞不好，你也看你自己不顺眼。
对吧这就是一个共情，简单的共情。生活中做这种练习，试试着走进每一个人。
我跟你讲，我练习共情。
我不光跟人练。
比如说咱这个房间里这空调。
你可不可以跟这个空调建立供气？
他在享受。
他有什么处境？
他有什么生士？
他有什么痛苦和快乐吗？
他每天在这兢兢业业的工作。
对吧夏天吹凉风，冬天吹暖风。
三年了。
他来的时候可不是一个人。
她跟她老公一起来的。
来了之后就分开了，她老公在阳台上空调外机。
男主外女主内吗？
对吧。
他们俩一起完成这个工作。
但是从来不能相见。
牛郎织女还一年见一回呢。
他俩三年没见过了。
而且他老公在外面风吹日晒。
已经生锈了。
生锈对于一个家电来说。
那就是癌症啊。
相信她老公撑不了多久了。
但是一旦她老公。
挂掉的话。
他也没有价值。
他也会被送走。
但是反过来又想。
他们那两天他们他们俩那天。
又能见面了。
所以你说。
他的人生是喜剧，是悲剧的。
你走到他的心里去替他想一想。
跟他也建立共情。
好吧。
共情也是一个刻意训练的方式。
然后你。
再讲最后一个。
很重要的训练方式啥呢？你看这个视频你都看到这儿了，证明你是有兴趣的。
你不管我我不管你是在哪看到的。
你可以关注一下这个账号。
我争取好好的把它录完，你也争取。
跟我一起学习研究一下。
好吧。
今天的课就上到这儿。
我给大家布置今天的作业。
今天的作业。
截下一个你的幻想。
幻想有没有撇？没有是吧？写下一个你的幻想。
我不说过吗？人人都有幻想。
金钱的。
权力的。
爱情的。
或者是职业生涯的。
为国争光的。
随便。
但是必须写真实的。
不用不好意思，我告诉你，不用不好意思。
你你说他就想拥有2亿，我想拥有5亿，我不好意思，没有什么不好意思，100亿的都有。
最真实的描述你怎么想的都给我写下来，你不会只想你拥有多少钱的，怎么花，你安排的明明白白。
包括。
拥有这这个钱之后，你的人物关系谱也会发生变化，跟现在不一样，你都想好了，我告诉你。
你会跟谁亲近，疏远谁，你都想好了，你给我把它描述出来。
好吧，去面对他，不要害羞，把你的幻想写下来。
这就是第一课的作业。后面我会告诉你他有什么用，好吧，下课。